wie kann man also die plausibelste
erklärung ist die dass es eben
verzögerte meldungen sind von
todesfällen das ist die plausibelste
erklärung wenn sie sich die zahlen über
die feiertage anschauen dann waren alle
zahlen relativ gering sowohl die
fallzahlen als auch die übermittelten
todeszahlen und die die plausibelste
erklärung wäre dass es verzögerte
meldungen sind aber was ich sagen will
und das ist das entscheidende
wir müssen uns eben deshalb zumindest
immer zeitraum über eine woche anschauen
das einer der gründe warum wir diese
sieben tage instanzen auswerten wie
sehen die verläufe innerhalb von einer
woche das halt nur für einen guten
zeitraum weil ja jeder wochentag einmal
abgedeckt ist um zu vergleichen hat
immer die sieben tages instanzen über
verschiedene woche und so werden wir
dann im januar genaueres sagen können
was das heißt wir haben wir diese ganzen
zuweilen systeme die wir jetzt auch
nutzen für pid haben wir schon seit
vielen jahren für influenza und das
heißt wir sehr viel erfahrung mit diesen
zahlen was die bedeuten und insofern
denke ich dass es die plausibelste
erklärung